[Music]
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we get no value to hat run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
one okay episode number
3:22 where is she
where is she Vinnie you you you you look
like somebody that that we know who's
that like Bruce B David or somebody
different very different character who
is this character here I don't even know
who are you we're just driving the bis
do is here the race can you still hear
it though Tom that's what I want to know
yeah are you even hearing anything are
you hearing anything through that helmet
of yours did did you say something yeah
exactly and then we got we got somebody
of here from where you from by the way
listen pbd I been a big fan for you for
a while now brother uh what's your nail
what's your name uh Jimbo Jimbo yeah no
last name go by one name like Sher or
Oprah uhhuh or Bruce Jenner who'd you
vote for come on player Ronda santis if
I if I have to wear this mask for one
more second let's just go to Rob first
my cheeks are about to blow up can you
focus on Rob please rob you're giving so
it's free memrs to everybody in the
office yes or anybody here what a
sweetheart
and your wife helped you make that nice
here I'll help you f up
some show show the whole like this is no
joke Lea I'm going to take this thing
off from top to bottom what you got let
see what you got here stand up real
quick go V let me see you I'm totally
this is this is a real vampire You Got
The Look come up here get your white ass
over here see what you look like huh
there we go prisoner or president yeah
look at that I to look president all
right let's my president let's get this
podcast started let's get it started
coming off I got I got my fangs in holy
if I wore this mask Sam must have been
pissed off Sam is laughing his ass off
right now buy an extra small hat oh my
gosh ridiculous get warm hey pbd when
you're as rich as Bruce Wayne and you
own the building you the hell what you
want you don't nowhere to mask Tom you
keep your damn helmet
on Adam pull the zipper down a little
bit on the back excuse me yeah yeah
exactly he's used to that yeah I beg
your part here we go go a little bit
more more in about 10 minutes I'm taking
this thing off I've been dreaming of
this my whole
life okay I've been waiting for you to
say help me with my zipper we got we got
a lot of stories to get into today we
got a lot of stories to get into
today see what we got here um Matthew
Perry obviously what happened with him
uh being dead at 54 years old after
parent drowning we'll talk about that
tragic uh Eragon threatens to declare
war on Israel and sends military uh to
gu AA and chilling warning US Marines
assault ship sailing towards Israel uh
over fears of regional conflict
development musk offers starlink
internet for recognized Aid
organizations in Gaza groups behind
Israel bashing protest uh backing Hamas
attacks got $50 million from the one and
only Soros Nikki Haley continues her
Ascent Tia santis for second in Iowa
gold standard pole pen suspense campaign
unfortunately Larry Elder drops out of
2024 crazed man and dragged from Hillary
Clinton event should have heard what he
had to say Professor Galloway wants
Grace he wants forgiveness for people
who pushed coid lockdowns we were doing
our best we'll talk about that we got to
play that clip for you cuz you got to
see how much grace he had uh IRS Chief
hints at possibility of audits may rise
for Americans earning under $400,000 so
folks if you're listening to this you
make less than 400k they may be coming
after you as well Americans can't stop
spending money five reasons why
why mapped where Americans are moving LA
and other liberal cities amongst biggest
targets as organized crime problems cost
retailers billions California and New
York lost a combined 1.4 million
residents in 2022 and then we got a
couple of stories McDonald's what what's
been happening with them price hikes you
ready for this at a McDonald's in
Connecticut the Big Mac combo bow went
for
$18 is that just high for me like do I
does that sound like an number number
one is like seven bucks that's 18 bucks
for a combo in Connecticut and it's not
like it's in the high-end shops it's
like you know where no no what do you
call it when trucks go through what do
you call trck truck stop yeah apparently
that's right truck stop I apologize Elon
Musk declares X will be a fully fledged
dating site within a year oh yes and
then last but not least us company shy
away from debt markets as treasury route
drives up cost by the way uh here's what
we're going to do by the end of the
podcast if we can make it with this 200°
uh temperature outfit that I got on uh
we will be announcing our next guest on
our live podcast and it is a
presidential candidate and some of you
guys will get a chance to meet him and
tickets will sell out in no time
specifically the ones to get a chance to
meet them in the Cigar Lounge in the
back so if you want to be one of the
first to get the link to uh get your
tickets before it sells out we will
announce it at the end of the podcast
text the word podcast to 3103 41132
again text a Word podcast to 310
34011 32 it'll be at our club 5990 live
okay and Rob put the link in details
below as well for people to go through
it Adam uh or Jimbo so so tell us about
your your outfit and why you're dressed
like this look man I think we all know I
for the past three four years we've been
doing the pbd podcast it's all been an
act we all know that you know who I am
on the inside this is who really who I
am everyone thinks that I'm just like
some leftist woke
banging Bud Light drinking weener
smoking type of guy it's not
me just just but I got you guys a gift
what you got us a gift hey you hot Pat
dude 200° you want something to cool
down with brother I got you Tom I got
you too buddy what' you get what see
Trump supporters are actually generous
you see that Tom hang on we got I think
there's something going on here America
first I think there's something going on
here uh here we go listen I'm not going
to lie I'm a little drunk all right I
want to make sure you can cool down with
me brother can I just want to have a
coule beer with are you going to do one
of these or no I don't drink I'm just
telling you this Tom's not even touching
it he won't even touch it he won't even
touch it wow listen listen you know UFC
just signed a deal with Bud Light yeah
Dana White Bud wiser or just Bud Light
Bud Light V
now listen boy um if Dana White approves
Bud Light it's all right it's got got be
right listen here I'm trying to make
budlight great again B I need your help
do you're doing it anyway I'm going to
have a beer Pat go go for none of you
guys are going to join me on a beer uh
after I have my protein and My Vault I
may but then that mixure I don't know
what it's going to produce can you
imagine Amer all of a sudden I turn into
something else have Okay so let's go
into which story do we want to get into
first do we want to get into uh I say we
Trump I say we get into California New
York loss they combined 1.4 million
residents in
2022 uh let's go to this number here to
see what the number looks like by the
way the the thing with this is Rob can
you also pull up the net migration
number as well CU this may be the uh uh
okay let's go through this and then
we'll see it okay so California New York
LW they combin 1.4 million residents in
2022 Florida and Texas are the big
winners in America America's ongoing
migration Trend with Florida gaining
249,000 residents Texas welcoming
174,000 more newcomers than departures
Arizona Georgia North Carolina saw more
Rivals coming in than departures while
California and New York combined for
nearly 1.4 million lost holy moly 1.4
million migration patterns are primarily
driven by employment housing
affordability lowering uh lower living
costs and tax consideration high taxes
elevated uh crime rates and an influx of
migrants are pushing people away from
States like New York while housing costs
and taxes are key drivers of California
population laws tough new environmental
rules such as the restrictions on
nonzero emissions vehicles are also
contributing to California's Exodus can
you imagine that restrictions on
non-zero missions vehicles and then at
the top the next story is La other
liberal cities among biggest targets as
organized crime problems cost retailers
billions Tom when you see the story what
do you think about well California New
York I'm going to do some math for you
1.4 million residents lost after the
last census each congressman and uh Rob
if you could pause the mogram for a
second maybe look this up I believe an
uh congressional district is now 750 a
little over 750 which means that
California and New York have lost each
one Congressman when we come up and we
do the uh the re assessment after the uh
census so what that means is California
I'll translate it the other way in
election year California New York have
probably each lost another electoral
vote the next time that we adjust the
playing field and there's going to be
new congressmen
probably probably one Texas one Florida
the way it's going that's the first part
I I look at this and I say people talk
about the Exodus we also have to
remember this Exodus is realigning our
government uh those are probably going
to be bright red or at least purple uh
if it happens to be in the Austin area
be more of a a purple representative but
that's the first thing that I see and
then the second thing I see is it is
that you know Bad actors are just taking
advantage of it like what's happening
with Los Angeles and the liberal cities
you know defund the police to all this
and now the crime is up you know I was
reading that the ox excuse me the Koga
Park Nordstrom that was in the San
Fernando Valley that we all saw this is
about 2 months ago the big looting and
Pat and I were there wait we used to
walk in that door with our wi all the
time from toena Canyon it was toena
Canyon Victory an area called Tanga uh
Canyon uh Tanga Mall um now it's I guess
Westfield or something but we used to
walk there and feel relatively safe
shopping there yet look at what was
happening there apparently that was an
organized crime group that did that that
massive Smash and grab and so defund the
police you know California wait you know
if it's not a ,000 we won't even
prosecute the theft you know you break a
window on a car take a laptop if it's
not more than a grand they don't you you
can report it to Insurance you know
what's crazy you're saying that that's
Tom they're pushing out and they're
causing this and they're going to get a
government restructuring but here's the
question though here's the question
though it says organized retail crime is
escalating across us where retailers
reporting you know how much inventory
loss it is does this seem like an insane
number $112 billion in 2023 let me say
one more time $112 billion doll in
losses not million billion guys Tom does
that sound like a big number that sounds
like a massive number to me if we were
to look at that hey do something real
quick I think I have a have one here Tom
why you yelling at Rob today Rob hey Rob
Rob can you look
up Levi Strauss Revenue last year
because to Pat's I'm wearing Levis right
now P's point we're going to see what
Levi stra revenue is and compared to 112
billion look at this
yep look at this 6 billion so what is
this this is 20
Levis wow 20 Levis to P point just do I
think it's a big number that's a massive
number you know about Levi Strauss right
Nazis you by the way saying they make
great jeans let me tell you don't be
wearing them buttonfly
501s cuz it takes them hookers longer to
open them damn right but I I have a
statement I have a question first of all
Vinnie talk like godamn vampire you need
velcro or zippers I mean Vinnie I can't
take cuz the whole time you were talking
he's just like damn bastards breaking an
ENT all right so I got something to say
but go here thing Vinnie go with Pat's
question this is 20 Levis no no no this
is where I'm going like Florida and
Texas they're saying uh Florida and
Texas are the big Winners I don't think
it's big Winners I don't think we're
winning that everybody wants to come
here because I I don't think it's going
to help us out but number one number two
Pat when you see something like that4
what 10 what billion 112 billion defund
the police all the I don't believe in
anything like oh we just wanted to do
because we we cared about cops killing
this seems like a concerted effort to
make all those shops shut down all those
places shut down where the government
has to go in and the government opens up
the businesses and then you have to and
they obviously they're going to have
their own security this isn't by
accident pack that's not a defund the
police and all these ,000 oh was it time
$1,000 wait wait wait wait wait are you
saying like our government's going to I
got to ask I I see where you're going I
understand you God bless you I love you
but I think you just said like the
government's going to operate malls and
got like well not not my America but Tom
my question is this you say they the
they say defund the police all the smash
and grab what wait make it make sense to
me you under $1,000 I think it was
$1,800 in some places there California
it was misdemeanor and they won't even
prosecute so that that's one thing so
you crime we're not going to get you in
trouble and and then uh defund the
police that's what's happening so you
that doesn't you don't see a pattern
where they're purposely doing it to make
all these places shut down that $15
billion you think that's just an
accident that just happened Tom I'm I'm
being genuine what what's the main goal
I don't look at it as face values take a
step back do kick his ass Vinnie do I
think there are globalists that like
what they're seeing here in terms of
civil unrest yes I do but do I think our
own government is somehow behind you
know let's let's this well the
government is behind Tom they're the
ones that saying defund the police and
they're the ones that are saying uh you
know crime under $2,000 is $1,800 isn't
a crime it's like they want the chaos
Tom why I'm asking why the chaos yeah I
think the globalist and the ones that
you know supported BLM and things and a
certain George Soros yes and a certain
Governor from Michigan uh which Gretchen
grety baby and uh yeah do I think they
want the civil unrest I think they want
to defund the police and that was their
agenda yes but government big g i no I
don't I don't think they want this I
think there's people in government the
squad and everybody that love the fact
this is happening and think of it as a
form of um income redistribution guys
this is called the pbd podcast not the
Tom and Vinnie circle jerk let you lived
in Pat you live the boy yeah Pat you
lived in California for how long hang on
hang on P Sam like 15 20 years 24 years
Vinnie Vinnie and I are going at it yeah
okay let the boy watch I'll but do you
think do you think it's a concerted
effort because what they're going to
shut down all this stuff they obviously
want us buy buying online with Amazon
and stuff did you guys see did you guys
see what the Disney uh guy who owns the
most shares came out said can you type
in out I don't even think we have that
story here type in Disney uh shareholder
you know he's A2 and half billion guy
put two and a half billion go to news
and 2 and a half billion says this guy
came out and said something uh go to new
zoom in a little bit yeah right there
right there that the first one right
there at the top so here's what you got
to look at that has to do with the story
in in La activist pelts wants multiple
seats at Disney owns $2.5 billion dollar
in Stak in Mickey Mouse Okay mous house
then you go lower and this guy says but
the Disney stocks down 30% the 82 year
old billionaire investors now expected
to ask the company for multiple board
seats including one for himself a person
familiar with the matter set on Monday
and then you know he's asking for
certain changes what they got to do
what's going on with you know New York
based try has increased its ownership
fivefold since then buying another 6.4
million shares of Disney that's a lot of
shares of Disney you own right and then
guess what's going on with these guys at
the board they're sitting there saying
what the hell are we doing with Disney
what are we doing with Disney guys we
got to make money I'm not putting money
into Disney because I'm running a
nonprofit I understand this liberal
stuff you guys got that you want to do
and we're listening to all these people
that are working at Disney that are
telling us how many candidates or actors
or stuff need to be part of the lgbtq
community if we start losing money we're
not happy right Disney shareholders that
makes it very honest why because you
have to produce a product that works for
people if malls are already getting
destroyed the mall business model is
already not working the M the mall
business model is already a think of the
past Mall today are more of a showroom
come here see this and then go buy
online how many people you see go to the
mall do this how many how many of you
have done this before you go you're like
okay let me see how this thing is then
you go straight on Amazon yeah discount
boom okay this thing's at $299 here I
can buy for 198 bucks on such and such
okay great babe order one of these it's
at your house the next day sometimes the
same day the other day we ordered
something for the kids at 1:00 by 6 o00
it was on our front porch I'm like wait
what do you why would you even go to the
mall yeah exactly why would you now you
order food comes to you now you order
shop comes to you so for me there's a
part of this $120 billion that these
businesses that are moving to States
like Florida you know Texas Carolina
some of these places it's because
capitalism is eventually going to get
the people who risk all their money who
spend hours months years working their
businesses risking all this stuff
they're going to say what are we doing
with all this stuff I don't think this
business model is going to work for too
long but they're destroying the mall
model for allowing people to shoplift
that's what I think
and I I wonder who's going to take over
those malls can I give you my thoughts
California yeah let's hear it look Pat
where am I from what state I would say
you're probably born and raised my whole
life Pat lobik Texas stop it don't
me now come on where are you
from bro you know where I'm from Pat
Florida I'm born and raised Florida I
went to school Tallahassee Florida been
living in Tallahassee
for half my life uh uh
California I've never lived there never
would show mhm no like I went to
San Francisco they were literally giving
Maps poop show so like the the woke
show that is California it's too
far gone you had Des santis on here
yesterday he's going to debate what's
that pretty boy or just say Nome this
freaking guy you hul employee of the
year three years running Gavin but he
goes on a Hannity and he's got his
little stats and his facts and he's and
Hannity he's lightweight you can't
compete with he's slick talking fast
talking just paid pay for play
politician you know what's probably
goingon to happen you know Joe Biden
ain't making it probably be this
Yahoo looking all plastic looking like
he's main character in American Psycho
you got to give him credit the way he
plays basketball do you have thatp of
him playing basketball he ran over one
of those commi kids in China and spanked
them I don't know if you saw that oh my
God that's what they do in Hollywood
Jimbo they spanked he spank did an
offensive that he might have
inadvertently started World War III he
charges him and then spanks this that's
your Governor go a little bit PRI yeah
play that because he's got a little bit
of game watch go
for hang look at that okay okay well he
yeah where he was probably born China
com China CCP behind the back that's
actually respect right there and I gu
those are
not oh there comes the Epstein move
thein move right there you don't spank
and then that's let me tell you
something if Trump was out there he'd
run over all those kids and dunk on
China yeah but he'd be in jail after
doing that he'd be whatever I'm just
saying like Gavin Newsome he ain't the
real deal we know that okay let's go to
the next story that was very insightful
very I mean California's a show we
know it it's too far gone Tom America's
Americans can't stop spending five
reasons why this is a Wall Street
Journal story uh on five reasons why
Americans can't stop spending here we go
number one job security and increased
income the job market strength marked by
consistent employment growth and low
unemployment rates has boosted consumer
confidence and provided more disposable
income number two home equity and low
mortgage rates increasing home value and
historically low mortgage rates have
empowered homeowners to tap into their
home equity stimulating consumer
spending and enhancing Financial
Security number three pandemic era
saving and government stimulus
government stimulus packages and reduce
spending during lockdowns resulted in
Americans accumulating over $2 trillion
in savings four the buy now mentality
consumers are adopting a proactive buy
now mentality to secure goods and
services at current prices driven by
concerns about inflation and economic
Outlook five a new outlook on life and
experiential exper uh experiential
spending a shift towards experiential
spending over material possessions has
emerged driven by pandemic induced
reevaluations of priorities Tom what's
going going on here so let's break this
down um they make some really good
points and some of them are very very
correct so job security increased income
unemployment is down people are back to
work so some of that is back in the
economy so that's true so that's just a
structural thing that's got nothing to
do with American spending that's just
more people that are working this year
than last year home equity and mortgage
rates uh Brandon and I were digging into
this and we're trying to find the home
equity thing because right now I want to
see what's going on with the helocs
because home equity line of credits um
it I've seen two reports that show that
they have come up this summer and not by
a small amount uh and also I saw that
the um uh the credit cards we talked
about this about a month ago in the
podcast are up to a trillion dollars so
if your credit card's up to a trillion
dollars but your house is up
30% you know credit card at 20% but a
HELOC at8 There's an opportunity to
unlock some of that uh value and turn it
into Cash Pander savings government stim
that is exactly the went down to 400
billion credit card rates and bounced
back to a trillion so that is true and
The Bu now mentality I think that's true
up to a point my brother redid his
kitchen and it was true he bought all
the appliances like like 9 10 months ago
and and did save money on buying them
putting them in his garage while they
were building out and doing the kitchen
and he did save money because in
inflation a couple of those appliances
were more just 6 months later so maybe
there's a little of that so I I I think
the Wall Street Journal has built a
story here around this but what we need
to look at is I think people are using
their helocs have maxed out their credit
card and help given the economy a great
third quarter let's see if it can
continue on Black Friday and holiday
spending V specific I I'm interested in
your Transylvanian insight about this do
people spend on experiences with you
people let me explain something to you I
know people people that spend money and
they ain't they ain't got the money yeah
uh save that
money okay I can't with them you the
whole time he's looking at him he's
shaking his head how can I look I'm
trying to simplify things I'm look goad
what I like about Trump he talks to the
fifth grade level literally okay go
ahead you got T Cruz out there talking
to 12th grade level to santis with his
you know mumbo jumbo policy policies I
think under I think underneath all this
Jim Bob you have an opinion I do cuz
you're talking about all this about
the economy uh thanks biomics what the
hell is even bomic serious I I I CH like
what's b i I have it's build from the
bottom up what no just make us go broke
and that's what it is that's bomic look
I just remember under Trump this is real
talk now lowest unemployment we've had
in 50 years okay for everybody pay
raises for blacks for Asians for Chinese
for Japanese for Latinos for one of them
one of them like shean people things
transgenders yeah they were doing good
too M Caitlin Jenner with the afrian
ameran stats in now what it's all Dei
ESG op I don't even know what's going on
you down with OP oh you know me but here
but listen yeah it's were you better now
or better four years ago just ask
yourself 4 years 100% yeah I mean they
had that the Wuhan flu whatever
shut down the country shut down
the world for what flu Jim Bob
can you just get back to us economics
I'm I'm genuinely asking a question Jim
B are you better now than you were for
be I'm I'm going to beer slap you if you
keep talking over me what I'm asking you
what is biomics tell me what it is
destroy it's destroy the the what what
is it I have no idea what the hell it is
it's not working what's the basic
premise of bad
nomics if if a person could even explain
that they they I would love to hear it
uh I would love to hear it but in
reality like this these these five
things explains exactly what's going on
in America today by the way you know
what's weird you know what the market
did yesterday up 550 yeah Bo up 550 and
that's the part about a reverse market
crash I mean the reverse market crash is
probably the one thing I'm most
concerned about it's one economically
because if a reverse market crash
happens the the the the concept of Rich
getting rich or poor getting poor you
know goes at a level that you've never
seen before St
you know people are still talking did
you see the CVS and Walgreens now want
to do a strike the three-day whatever
they got going on CVS and
Walgreens and the auto worker who's the
one that agreed on the price UA yeah I
know what's the number is that in here
Rob do we have the UAW store here that
they finally agreed to UAW
strike it was Ford caved in it and then
Detroit Detroit is paying up to end the
UAW strike now car makers will live with
the cost now car makers will live with
the cost pay 16 Wall Street Journal
story you know the the the speed of
which cost of living is increasing is is
insane here Detroit six-week strike by
UAW against Detroit's automakers
including GM Ford and Stanis ended with
tentative labor deals but these
Agreements are sent to increase labor
costs Beyond initial expectations Ford
CFO John Lawler noted that the UAW
contract would add $850 to $900 per
vehicle in additional costs the tenative
agreements include a 25% General wage
increase over four years with cost of
full uh living adjustment raising the
top pay for production workers to
approximately $42 an hour yeah $42 an
hour the UAW are also secured the return
of cost of living adjustment and other
benefits such as the right to strike
over planted closures and higher pay for
temporary employees so you hear a number
like this what do you hear you you say
okay what's the word they use the the
cost of living adjustment cost of living
adjustment cost of living adjustment
when the military they do that too when
you move to a different place yeah but
this is real though and what what's
causing this you put trillions of
dollars in the economy the rich got
richer the poor got poor and everything
got more expensive by the way even the
next store here you go to which makes
zero senses right before that if you go
to page 15 and Pat add this how much is
a new car these days oh forget it comp
what it was 3 years ago I'm not
bullshitting right now no I know you're
not bullshitting you're you're very real
cars are as expensive as ever been
depreciating assets yep and now they're
you know what they're going to do Tom
super I'll make this super quick ladies
and gentlemen 850 in new additional
vehicle costs is going to translate to
1,500 bucks in showroom price of Ford
makes a profit the showroom makes a
profit the dealer makes a profit that
900 in cost is probably 1,500 on the
sticker and who ends up paying the
burden for that Tom we do the guy
customer the guy looking at the to buy
the car it's like this minimum wage
fight for 15 25 uh they just
raised something in California some
ridiculous number minimum wage for
restaurant we all know that these
businesses need to make a profit all
they're going to do is end up passing it
down to the consumer how much is a
McDonald's these days mind this
story is wild let me let me read the
story to you McDonald's Revenue sores as
it hikes menu prices I wonder why they
hike menu prices is it accidental cuz
they're paying 16y old kids $15 an hour
can you actually show that price all the
way at the top to McDonald's Big Mac
look at this I still it's unbelievable
$18 Big Macs what the hell are you
talking about and you get closer
McDonald's Reports say 14% increase in
Revenue remember revenue revenue not net
revenue revenue the revenue is different
than net uh for the latest quarter
latest quarter contributor ruting the
search to strategic menu price increases
the company generated $6.6 billion $6.69
billion of Revenue surpassing analyst
expectations McDonald's did not disclose
specific price increases but mentioned
that a branch in Darian Connecticut
charged as much as 18 bucks a combo for
a freaking Big Mac combo meal which
includes medium fries and medium soft
drink no sushi no rainbow roll no
nothing we're talking just a Big Mac is
what we're talking about here uh while
the same combo cost 13369 at McDonald's
and Time Square so 1369 for a Big Mac
combo 18 bucks in Connecticut net income
Rose $2.3 billion on 1.98 in the same
period the same store sales in US
increased 8.1% largest driven by Price
hikes the company expects to raise men
uh menu prices by just over 10% for the
full year marking the second consecutive
annual 10% increase by the way I wonder
why I wonder why why this is the concept
that you know it goes it's it's almost
like you know which one comes first you
know the egg or the chicken you know
that whole thing that you do which one
comes first putting fake money into the
economy or is it you know uh uh
increasing minimum wage or companies
being forced to have to increase prices
but regardless this is going to keep
feeding it more and more and more cars
Homes apartments food you know fast food
it doesn't matter prices are going up %
increase 2 years in a row you know what
that is if you're if you're if the food
you're buying for your family four kids
okay we don't go to McDonald's but if we
do go to McDonald's say for four kids
you're going to buy something a husband
wife and four kids let's just say you're
spending 50 bucks 60 bucks bucks 60
bucks 10% is what 66 go 10% against 73
72 I mean 72 6 so you're going up $113
on $60 in two years okay and it's not
like they're giving you more meat more
fries
same Tom so there's two things
going on here the first thing is people
don't seem to understand that McDonald's
is getting a volume benefit out of
inflation first of all McDonald's
raising the prices and they're going to
make more profits and you've got a place
in uh Darian Connecticut which this in
Fairfield County Connecticut a very
wealthy suburb of New York
was and so so but here's the other side
the
you know you know where these customers
are these customers maybe would have
gone to chili for lunch no they're
coming to McDonald's McDonald's is the
beneficiary of some of the workforce
that might have gone to a Ultra fast
casual you go to tji Fridays you go to
chili things along that line a Chipotle
which is more than McDonald's and M so
basically people are coming back down
the restaurant food chain for lunch
because of inflation because those other
places are more expensive and McDonald's
itself along the way is more expensive
this is a net negative for the health of
America because I I if my nephew was
telling me he was eating lunch at
McDonald's every day I'd start I I'd sit
down with him and say dude man you need
to take a take a little lunch box or a
cooler to work with some healthy stuff
because that is not healthy for you
that's not good for you but it's all I
can afford we used to go to Chipotle and
stuff like that and I've kind of shifted
a little bit because it's more expensive
that's the net negative here is we have
middle-sized businesses that are getting
squeezed McDonald's is recipient of that
way and they had to raise I do want you
to say something but check this out
here's a crazy thing even though they
increased it by 10% and they're going to
do it again the way the customers
responded is by doing what nothing they
still went and they're up 6.69 Billion
over the quarter so you know what
McDonald's sitting there thinking about
maybe we can go another 10% and another
10% and another 10% cuz you know the
only way the the the consumer gets to
vote is what with their pocketbook and
they're not and they're not they're
saying yeah we'll still keep coming back
go ahead and there's more of them I
believe that are coming from other more
expensive lunch
choices I just want to keep it super
simple there's two things I get at
McDonald's number one the MC rib when it
comes out once a year you know that you
know how bad that is though for you
Jimbo F it's not even on the menu all
the time cuz they know it's poison it's
fine I love that M rib but here's the
real deal yeah uh I love the dollar menu
oh yeah let me ask you something guys
fellas okay uh what's going to happen
when the dollar menu is the $4 menu well
it's already the dollar store is in the
dollar you the Dollar Tree is a dollar
inflation bomic now you're paying
$399 for a cheeseburger dollar menu y
it's like how far do we have to go to
realize we are going backwards yeah
literally just look at the dollar menu
Tom that's you know you got your charts
you know you're comparing GD P you're
doing you know the dollar the Yen I say
how much is the dollar menu at
McDonald's and I compare that to the
other currencies around there so if a
dollar menu is now $3 menu yeah just
times everything by three that's what it
is but you know I want to ask a question
too Pat where's the outrage where with
besides everything else that's happening
with all of our domestic or
International everything that we're
doing where is the outrage of the
American people that are that are seeing
stuff like this that are just like
where's the why aren't they upset no
we're upset people are upset Vinnie what
do youan no I'm not seeing I'm not
seeing it I'm not CU you're probably
watching mainstream Legacy news there
was a different president in president
was in what would be happening right now
listen the dollar menu would probably go
down to 50 CS but I'm saying where's the
I'm just saying like things would go
cheaper you know what I'm saying though
you know what I mean where's the where
are the people Furious I mean listen if
we're talking serious I'm talking dead
this does nothing for me I'm not
affected by this because I don't go to
McDonald's and I'm not affect it doesn't
affect a guy like me because I'm not uh
uh you know sitting there worrying about
buying a Big Mac at 18 bucks in freaking
Connecticut uh but it's affecting the
average person and the residual effect
of it is the following it only comes
back to the business owner and then the
business owner has to raise prices and
then the business owner has to ask more
money from the customer so then this so
so so they like I'm I can't believe
you're increasing your prices well then
stop forcing me to increase the pay or
if you want me to increase pay be okay
if I'm increasing the prices and don't
but can you imagine McDonald's comes out
and says well we had to do because they
force us to increase the minimum wage we
have to pay 16y old kid at McDonald's 15
bucks an hour seriously you want to pay
I was getting paid 375 or 425 at Burger
Kings but I got paid at yeah of course
and by the way here's a fun fact for you
you know when the last time had a when
the last time you had a big man the when
was the last time you had a Big Mac do
you remember I can tell you the exact
month and year the last time you had a
big mine
was three months ago okay Tom I loved it
though maybe maybe once in the last two
years maybe Adam uh a couple weeks ago
but I take off all the bread and just
eat so the last time I had a Big Mac was
September of 1997 you want to know why7
cuz you went to war Bloods and Crips as
Burger King McDonald's you worked at
Burger King your first career you were
last time I went to McDonald's was uh at
Fort Campbell Kentucky this is after
boot camp I get to my unit I can't wait
to have a Coke I've been on I've been on
boot camp and AIT just watering that the
punch they put that reduces your
testosterone level that everybody talk
about what's happened in America we went
to McDonald's I ate Big Mac I couldn't
wait to have one I ate it and I drank
coke I started throwing up I felt bad
and I never ate it
wow yeah never again you ever see that
movie that documentary super me 30 days
this guy McDonald's for 30 days ID was
eating everything all day that's what
McDonald's does to be honest I love I
love I was a I loved Big Mac but then
after the Army 6 months I couldn't do it
it just wouldn't let me do it yeah well
think about your body was eating just I
mean regular stuff besides the Sal Peter
but listen and I tell people this all
the time that bash McDonald's this guy's
an idiot McDonald's isn't supposed to be
everyday breakfast lunch and dinner it's
like it's like a cheating you're putting
a little bit of poison and you and by
the way that helps you build your immune
system because your immune system Tom
needs some practice to fighting that's
why I never got Co you know why every
day I had a Big Mac listen I don't know
where you're from Transylvania
Pennsylvania whatever it is whatever the
average working man yeah all right he a
EED Whole Foods he ain't going no fancy
place the pbd goes all all the time he
eats regular McDonald's go to fancy
places like Jersey
miks I'm just saying like this food
fried food carbohydrates we can be hard
McDonald's on the nutrition value and I
certainly will but I'll tell you the
McDonald's french fries should be in the
French fry Hall of Fame those are the
best they are probably the best french
fries Burger King's french fries sucks
wait you're letting them call them
french fries aren't they Freedom fries
if you Vinnie Vinnie aren't they Freedom
fries brother I'm proud to be an
American where least know I love that
song we have a professor that's looking
for some Grace okay so please be
respectful we have a professor if you
can pull up the video Rob we have a
professor that is looking for some Grace
from everybody okay and and then then
Professor wants forgiveness for people
who pushed coid lockdowns we we were
doing our best is what he said on Bill
Mah okay Professor Scott Galloway of New
York University I wanted a harsher
lockdown policy in retrospect I was
wrong we were all operating with
imperfect information and we were doing
our best
but let's uh bring a little bit of Grace
okay we can play that clip in a minute
here but yallow is advocating for
amnesty over individuals who support a
CO 19 lockdown policies regretting for
initially wanting stricter lockdowns and
acknowledging the greater damage to
Children education Galloway highlighted
the significant decline in test scores
among students particularly in math and
reading start stating math scores are
dropping to levels not seen since the
1970s with scores for black students
falling more than twice as much as white
students he emphasized
that policy makers were operating with
imperfect information and call for
understanding and forgiveness in light
of the challenges posed by the pandemic
I think Scott you kind of knew what you
were doing brother you're a professor at
NYU you were less worried about what it
was going to do to education you were
more worried about getting grit of
somebody which you succeeded go ahead
and play this clip yeah was on the board
of my kids school during coid I wanted a
harsher lockdown policy and in
retrospect I was wrong the the the
damage to kids of keeping them out of
school longer was greater than the risk
but here's the bottom line myself our
great people the CDC I'd like to than
the governor we were all operating with
imperfect information and we were doing
our best it's
it's applause applause
no let's learn from
it I don't think uh I don't think uh
Bill Mah was with him there you don't
think I don't think Bill Mah was with
him there I don't think Bill Maher is
looking at that saying
hey you're right all this other stuff
look when I see somethingone like this
you know what I think about here's what
I think about I think about I asked the
governor a question yesterday Governor
Des Sanz uh I asked him I said what's
more important to you uh America
political party or your own personal
Ambitions and he said what the cause he
says the cause which by the way I
respect it me too I respect the fact
that you say that's what it is now I
don't think to Democrats it's the cause
I think it's the party first firste I
think it's the party first before it is
America and I know some people are not
going to like this and FYI some people
may say but I also think for Mega it's
Mega before it's America and they can
make that argument for themselves we got
a mega guy here that can talk for
himself and say what he's going to say
about that but when when you when you
see that opportunity anything and
everything that was done nothing was
right at that time now you want to
apologize and now you know what he's got
look at the look on his face on that
picture that Rob perfectly just paused
you know what that look is you ever
bought a car you ever bought something
and you left the store REM buyer remorse
and you're like man I shouldn't you ever
had have you ever had that happen to you
what did you buy can you remember one
product what did you buy that you had
buyers of remor buyers it was a it was a
car when I was in Great Falls Montana it
was a Chevrolet p and that's all they do
is that that town made money just from
all military people cuz we were young
and stupid and it was the biggest
mistake what was it for you Tom do you
have buyers REM
yeah I bought Alexis GS way back in 2005
and um you know how long did it take you
to have it literally the whole detail
just how long did you did it take you to
have it about three months when I
realized that bab the kid seat wouldn't
fit in the back and the trunk was a
little bit like what I do with it and
I'm stuck with it for three years that's
exactly right so why didn't I think of
all this stuff why didn't I measure this
have you you've had vir bug Light yeah
no uh my first wife Pat okay all right
well that makes sense that makes sense
so but here here
look at his look on his face you know
what the look is you know what his you
know what his look is a buyer's remorse
look yep buyer remorse on policies
during lockdown buyers remorse on the
president they got stuck with buyers
remorse on getting everybody on a super
Tuesday to drop out Amy Elizabeth Bernie
you know everybody Pete everybody
stepped out and they got behind Biden
when he was behind in New Hampshire I
think it was third or fourth place when
they got behind him and he's looking
there saying man
hate to say it the other guy cannot
stand the other guy and by the way this
the same guy that trash you know what he
said about El do you know who this guy
is this guy this guy when Elon Musk say
I'm G to buy 99.6% of Twitter he says
he's lying make him do it oh this is the
guy and then he says Elon Musk is buying
Twitter he's never goingon to do it he's
just fooling all of you guys you guys
are idiots for falling for Elon Musk and
then when Elon Musk bought Twitter and
he kept his commitment and bought it and
then he still trashed them M so if there
is a guy that's got zero Grace and
asking for Grace it's this guy this is
the typical Professor that's so smart
above and by the way you know who else
this guy is this is also the guy that
took a million bucks I think give or
take from CNN plus and no one's ever
seen the content and the show that CNN
plus had with Scott Galloway by the way
to give him credit I did a episode and I
gave him a lot of love because he's got
one episode he did on boys on on what
boys should do he said they should make
more money they should have more sex
they should work out something like that
he talked about how boys need to go out
there so he understands like he has
logic M he he's able to process issues
but he he was he was afraid he was
afraid of standing up to the gang he was
a part of to have some brass and say
guys I disagree with what you all are
doing group thing when everybody all of
a sudden is like you know agreeing with
each other it's like nah I don't agree
with you bro let's hash it out he joined
that group and as a professor who claims
to be This brilliant guy you missed the
mark Cuz you could have gained so much
respect during Co and you would have had
a back then now you're asking for Grace
did you give anybody else Grace does
your reputation have anything to do with
Grace were you wer giving Grace to
anybody did you now you want it by the
way here's a crazy thing people are
still going to give you Grace America's
going to give you Grace God's going to
give you Grace you didn't give Grace and
you're still going to get Grace because
that's how this thing uh works that's
how America Works America will forgive
you and move on but deep down inside I I
got to give you credit at least that you
said you were wrong salute to you I
respect the fact that you come out
saying I you know I I maybe was a part
of the wrong side totally fine but that
decision four years ago is why America
and why the world is in shambles today
because of people like you and I'm going
to take it up one more level because he
said he was wrong but I didn't hear an
apology and I think we owe the people
the the athletes that we fired the
servicemen that we fired the teachers
that we fired that lost their pensions
on that day lost their pension
accumulation on that day where's the
apology to say let's bring a little
Grace and forgiveness and can we
apologize to these people and bring them
back to their jobs and restore their
pensions to the day that we that we
kicked them out and I applaud him for
bringing up the data of black students
but you have a voice Scott Galloway you
have a voice and you have a megaphone
and you have a platform and that
platform is based on education you're
section four and everything that you do
where are you calling for summer school
and things that we can help these kids
kids catch up after we took them out of
school for 2 years I think there's
another level that's deserved here and I
think he should be calling for an
apology and to bring back a a you want
to talk about you know reparations how
about reparations just very simply
putting people back in the place they
were when we fired them during Co mhm
Tom I like that you're fired up and you
deserve every right to be fired up let
me tell you something I actually know
this guy Scott Galloway I've been
following Bill Mah I watch all this
stuff you know this he no lightweight
the reason that we're upset with Scott
Galloway he ain't no just fly by CNN
anchor talking head he's a guy
he's wrot written articles saying the
most dangerous person in the world is a
broke lonely man with a cell phone he's
done articles about this he ain't no
lightweight but here's what he gets
wrong and this is no he is the
typical Ivory Tower Coastal Elite New
York City NYU Professor that thinks he
knows more than anybody else just cuz
he's been working to school for 50 years
who got mad and moved to England during
Co thank you so but I I don't have beef
with Galloway he actually does some
really good work for young men out there
and I got to applaud him for that but
you know who are you to tell people what
to do during Co I'm not even
bullshitting right now Vinnie I believe
it like
so the the problem is California we
talked about California M the the the
Gavin Newsome Nancy Pelosi stock
situation whatever I don't know what
happened with their husband and my buddy
and then you have New York hammer time
okay they think they run the country
Wall Street and Hollywood Silicone
Valley uh there's a lot of states in
between you know they said back in the
day in the 80s and 90s uh a broadcast TV
they said win the central time zone you
in Chicago you wi Iowa you win Minnesota
you went Missouri not drunk pet uh
that's what America is Google it Rob win
the central time zone problem is we got
the Hillary
Clinton New York Senator that
she's doing you got everything that's
going on out there with gav new they
want to run the country but there's a
lot of states in between someone like
Galloway smart guy just misinformed and
you know what and they cancelled any
conservative voice that wanted to talk
about this this not man I I
just can't take you serious with the I'm
just nothing I'm saying bull ACC and I I
wrote I I wrote a bunch but how about
screw an apology you know what I want I
want accountability it's how fast we
forget beautiful Adam because now time
has gone by Pat there's so much stuff
happening in the news how about the
system is set up for them never to get
in trouble do you think do you think
fouchi would have bullshitted from
everything from where it came from to
mass everything if he didn't know Adam
that he had to get out of jail free card
you don't you don't go out there and
speak the that you spoke knowing it
was a lie and KN and without without a
get out of jail free card and by the way
the whole industry had to get out of
free fre yeah yeah hold on Adam hold on
nobody has gone to jail for Co for what
they put us to think about from forcing
the lockdowns to destroying people's
lives livelihood people are living in
the streets and some people are freaking
dead because of the lockdowns they
forced masks on children's and then they
forced vaccinations they brainwashed
parents to shove needles in their kid to
put this freaking poison in that I I I
read a report P what 50% of these kids
are going to grow up to have myio
carditis okay and myio carditis is
you're done you're not going to you
don't recover from myio carditis uh and
and they knew about the Wuhan the the
the lab okay Bingo you know who did go
to jail parents went to jail restaurant
owners who serve food for the
unvaccinated hair stylists for doing
people's hair all right and Priests who
didn't want to shut down churches
because they knew people needed God
during those times those people went to
jail so I'm never going to forget them
and I don't think any body should forget
them unless we hold them accountable
through the law it's almost like once
once enough time goes by Pat people
forget I don't forget all right and it's
interesting to me how you see
politicians on the left like Maxine
Waters Nancy Pelosi Cory Booker they're
on camera always calling for for people
to get in Americans faces you know you
see these politicians get in their faces
well guess what okay I'm I'm going to
give you guys a little shout out if you
see people that ruined our lives because
of the pandemic like fouchi or all the
pieces of trash get in their faces you
see any of these get in their
face and be like you ruined our lives
you ruin this country and remember uh Dr
McCulla Peter McCulla yeah Peter McCulla
during the pandemic uh he was silenced
during the pandemic remember that he was
crazy cons get him off get him off so we
could sell this poison the CDC says that
approximately 1.2 million Americans have
died from Co 19 but those numbers are
inflated says Peter Mulla he said when
there's an analysis of of of did they
really primarily die of Co pet the
answer is it's 10% of that so it's
roughly 120,000 Americans died directly
of coid so ready for this 540,000
vaccine deaths versus
120,000 uh coid deaths The Cure was
worse than the disease so my point is
and again Pat going back to why and what
when do we hold them more accountable I
can give a about that weirdo and
his apology and this is way deeper than
him it's the government it's the FBI
everything that they did to us Pat that
they ruined us and all the stuff that
we're talking about money and inflation
and putting trillions in the economy
it's because of them and those all
and they all knew it all of
them binnie what I'm thank you I love
how passionate about this you're
absolutely right yeah and we need to
talk about this let me
say I was just going to say and to
Vinnie's point about the inflated
numbers when it comes to co deaths look
at these numbers it seems like 2017 18
we had 52,000 people that died of the
flu now you fast forward to 2021 2022
postco only 5,000 people died from the
flu so somehow in those 3 or 4 years we
managed to solve the
influenza but
where what a great oneth of the
amount of people di in 2021 that's mam
the point you're making is the
comorbidity excuse me no it's
all good and what they did was they
wanted to count every death possible as
a coid death and so what he's showing
here is that you know what elderly
people God bless them I'm watching over
my mom at 82 years old they get the
pneumonia as a result of the flu and
that it unfortunately is a leading cause
of death during flu season for a lot of
elderly but did they suddenly developed
better immune systems to counter the flu
no no no they were recounted that was
probably a CO death that was a CO death
that was a just very very quick I know a
guy that's admin in a hospital and I'm
not joking this is peak pandemic Peak
pandemic and and he a Syrian guy I don't
want to say his name cuz he's probably
watching you know what he said Vinnie
there's a motorcycle accident the guy
comes in he's dead you know what they
didn't count it as a motorcycle accident
he they were like he had Co we're going
to put it in that and they incentivize
the family I swear to God federal
government was giving money to hospitals
incentivizing them to reclassify cuz my
understanding that was worth 3500 bucks
more and so Pat and I know you wanted to
make your point do do you feel Pat like
people like a fouchi yeah he's protected
you don't want to see that guy pay for
what done I you don't want to see that
guy in prison oh no there listen there's
a big difference between grace and a big
difference between accountability those
are two different things 100% the the
the the challenge with Grace is the
opposing side typically has way more
grace than the Left Right always has
more grace than the left always always
it's not even close do you know if you
flip the script like let's just say if
Republicans wanted to pull a page out of
uh the democratics uh uh uh mainstream
media Playbook you know what they would
do look at the level of protesting
they're doing right now they're not even
worried about a breakout what if there's
a flu breakout what if there's a they
would have used that to play the dumbest
things they would have used to to the
fastest right right now to stop these
wars is say there's Co fastest way
there's Co CO's making a comeback go you
guys can't go you guys got to have a six
feet distance before you shoot each
other you cannot do this you cannot do
that the gameification they used one day
we're going to be in a movie theater
okay and we're going to sit there
someone's going to make the movie okay
maybe us and we're going to sit there in
the movie theater and we're going to
watch all of these stories of what
happened all of these stories of what
happened and we're going to say damn man
I cannot believe that's all the we
went through for three years we're going
to watch it and people going to relate
to it left right and Center no one's
going to care about politics cuz guess
who got fired you think only Republicans
got fired no Democrats got fired you
think only Republicans lost businesses
no the left also lost businesses you
think only how if you were to ask if you
were to ask actually think about the
question by the way this Batman outfit
is so tight my voice is about to change
to uh but if you were to if you were to
think about during Co did Co caus more
people to go from right to left or did
Co cause more people to go from left to
right I think at the towards the end of
it once it was left to right today left
to right 100 if anybody knows it Adams
knows it right by the way check check
left leing moderates that were upset
about losing their freedoms went right
so so the left they moved out of
California to Florida here's what the
left doesn't realize here's what the
left doesn't realize to DN these clowns
that have these decrees from Berkeley
who are smarter than everybody else and
we're just regular people that don't
know what we're talking about
right these guys uh are the same people
who thought they're winning the battle
hey look what we're going to do we're
going to get rid of that guy yeah but
what you did do is a lot of the people
from your own party they left you know
like who Rogan voted for Bernie Sanders
and he's saying good things about Trump
and you know the santis and Republican
Elon Musk has been a liberal his entire
life and now he's saying vote Republican
shamat voted for Hillary Clinton and
Biden oh God and now he's saying go the
other side kids are coming out saying
what are we talking about so short term
they may have won and got rid of the guy
that they fear the most cuz he was the
anti-establishment guy MH long term
they're going to be the ones that gets
to credit for the biggest Exodus the
left experience in decades by the way
yesterday I asked a question from uh the
governor about how Democrats own the
black vote since 1964 and I gave the
example about you know Netanyahu feeling
like he has the America vote 80% they're
going to care you know whatever we do
they're going to support us etc etc
Democrats have thought yeah we got the
black vote every once in a while go talk
about reparations make them feel good
but they're going to vote for us they're
not voting Republican trust me we've had
them since bury
goldw yeah they're going to vote for US
ah
don't going to vote for but that level
of arrogance is about to pay a price and
trust me when I tell you this the right
is always has more grace than the left
always I agree they always have they
don't forget it's a different story they
want accountability people going to be
held accountable but they're going to
they're going to forgive because they're
going to say at least at the end of the
day God is in charge at the highest
level they trust God to do his part
sometimes something happens to you where
you feel it's unfair and you're helpless
and you're like dude this just what was
this all about what did I do to deserve
what and then all of a sudden you're
like dude just can you be a little bit
patient God can you just have a little
bit of patience have a little bit of
patience if you really believe on who I
am have a little bit of patience take a
year 3 years 5 years just chill out and
you'll see all like oh my God that's the
plan I was not expecting something like
this this kind of a Revival what was
this all about that's the patience that
you got to have it's coming going to be
a matter of time pat is absolutely
correct if you look over history there's
two truths people go slowly to the left
like the indoctrination of your kids in
college but they will go suddenly to the
right just look through the pages of
History that's how it happens you talked
about accountability I just want to give
you one thing yeah what the hell is the
accountability for China uh Fouch okay
fine yeah China I've said this Adam they
get at listen me saying something to you
China we're we're not we're in a war
with China but it's not bullets and
bombs they have infiltrated our kids
Minds with Tik Tock they're hold on
they're buying land near military bases
they flying balloons Gavin Newsome is
over there charging sping little kids
it's as if they're they're winning on so
many levels bro but they haven't shot to
more thing next big Pharma obviously how
much money did they make during Co
trillion you did a whole episode on this
at least a trillion bucks they made a
lot of money we have to the CEO of f
guys a couple questions can I ask you
guys a couple questions crazy questions
I want to ask you okay crazy questions I
want to ask you and I just want to see
your reaction to it okay I want to see
your reaction to it fentol how much have
you guys actually looked into fentanyl
what it does the power of it what it's
I've actually lost two friends in
California before I moved here Pat they
went to a friend's house
two of my really close friends one of
them had a girlfriend they were partying
everybody did I I guess they did a bump
of cocaine everybody everybody dead
you're two comedian buddies remember two
comedian friends remember that was on TC
and everything so two of them dead the
other girl that was there she apparently
she almost she almost went bye-bye but
Pat the you can die from it could fit on
the tip of this a little bit of pencil a
little bit of pencil and you're done
you're pH by the way have you seen the
cops that are finding it in cars passing
out almost they they from the One Cop
didn't want to give the uh at first
she's like I don't want this video to be
viral shown and then she puts it gets 15
million views Nar can and they Naran
there right oh they had to cuz she was
dying and and this one of them happened
just two weeks ago uh uh when when you
see these clips it's disturbing you know
it's the leading cause of death between
18 to 45 year olds do you know how much
more powerful it is than heroin fentanyl
fentol how much more powerful powerful
is it than heroin heroin what you isn't
it a bizarre number like 2000 50 times
more powerful than heroin mhm think
about how powerful heroin is okay this
is 50 times more powerful and people
keep it's people keep dying and they
keep selling it yeah they keep selling
it and people's like no it's not it's
going to I'm I'm going be okay with it's
going to be disturbing it's not going to
be that bad I'm going to be able to
handle I'm going to be able to hand boom
right there if you can play this clip oh
my so she just went in the car P she
just went in the car look at this how's
the driver watch this
oh my God y got it look she's done oh my
God y
z that is insane she's a cop she's not
using it she just I know she just walked
in the
vehicle another one happened last week
that is some scary crap dude did they
lose her no she come back she came back
by way but do you know do you know the
craziest thing about fentol it's FDA
approved yeah yeah cuz when you go under
they you pull up a fentol fentol FDA Pro
for like when you when you're getting
put under and anesthesiologist they use
fentol FDA approved okay watch this
fentol is a patent synthetic opio drug
approved by the Food and Drug
Administration for use of anal analistic
pain relief and anesthetics it is
approximately 100 times more important
than Morphin and 50 times more important
than heroin but it's approved by the FDA
wow okay approved by the FDA we just
killed one person that's been documented
okay one person one person only one
person's ever died from can you pull up
how many people have died from marijuana
so crazy how many people have died from
marijuana look at the number from
marijuana it's one person undocumented
that is insane it's the only it was this
girl she was 39 years old I think it was
like five six years ago and what
happened she just got no she just died
from and and by the way they don't even
know if the full story was from it or
not BL we're not I'm not even a guy
endorsing smoking weed I'm not sitting I
don't smoke weed but the moral of the
story is fentol is FDA is FDA approved
because it's more effective than
morphine or vicadin that they give you
this is an issue because kids in schools
nowadays man they're around this stuff
you know there's a bunch of clowns and
and people that are testing and are like
well listen how tough are you you know
no all these people are trying to scare
you people are not dying I know how to
do the high is amazing and all this
other stuff right we have so many ISU so
many issues right now 8 million people
crossing the border Y and when you when
you think about the kind of money that's
being made with fentol right now and
what it's doing to the point where even
the cartel last week we talked about
cartel saying hey you guys better stop
producing this stuff 100% so P so the so
those deaths the 112,000 in one year one
year that falls on China cuz China's
bringing it and the number one producer
the number one is China so remember I
told you about this war they haven't
shot one gun but nobody gives a
about this do you know what your fentol
production and sale increase do you know
what your it's skyrocketed 2016 2015
201d what a what a odd thing by the way
when I show you the data Brandon could
you show me that chart could you text me
that chart so I can show it to uh uh if
you're listening there's a chart that
you look at on the production of it's
always been like this okay it's always
been like this it's always been flat and
then all of a sudden boom goes like this
and every year goes more and more and
more and more and more when you think
about the amount they're producing and
amount of people that are dying from it
in
2016 who was elected in 201 what mean Co
and Fentanyl they're winning bro they're
winning they won Donald Trump 2016
greatest PR ever here's the
deal Trump build the wall yep you know
one of the most ironic things is right
now what you know what Joe Biden wants
to do he's already started this build
the wall yep sometimes you know like how
many by is building the wall mhm with
his build back better he said he wasn't
by the way but that's the point build
like is there's some people out there
that maybe fell for the walls of racist
what do you mean did they
everybody fell for it say fell for it
but at this point when you have millions
of immigrant illegal immigrants and how
many came from the Middle East a bunch
uh excuse me is uh Iran near Mexico no
how they getting there everybody's
coming here Lebanese syrians everybody
rob I'm going to send this to you you
got to show this you you got to show
this when we're on the fentol topic
build a wall I mean it's a delay dollar
short Adam the damage has been done I'm
actually not even joking Obama and Biden
built the cages exactly Rob pull up the
one I just text you check this out guys
you got to see this good point you got
to see this okay by the way you know
what you are starting to see even though
Adam's playing this Jimbo guy I love it
he's being straight up about what he's
saying everything I'm saying is accurate
the point the point the point is even
the people that thought building a wall
was stupid are now saying guys we need
to build a damn wall okay to prevent
this think about how bad policies get
exposed and how good policies eventually
everybody including those who disagreed
with it come around and say N I think
this kind of makes sense watch this take
a look at this guys this is kind of
disturbing and look at the data what
year it spikes oh my God fentol was
responsible for nearly 70% of drug
overdosed deaths in 2022 but look at the
numbers over the years it's been FDA
proof for a long time of course look at
that boom boom boom boom 2015 2016 TR
goes off and then Skyrocket it to where
it's at today um and this can be stopped
but it's going to take a lot of work so
the border is an issue uh that uh go
ahead and what happened with Joe Biden
did he just cut some deal with the
Mexican cartel right we covered that a
few a week or two ago yeah well but but
he's basic here's the deal he's
basically acknowledging look I can't say
out loud build the wall or cut illegal
immigration I can't say it cuz my party
doesn't want that but he knows he sees
what's going on and pat pat you nailed
it the last remember last I think it was
two weeks ago you said one year shut it
down I don't give send the milit whoever
stop it the border for one year one year
and I'm sick and tired of people saying
that there's no money in it we've given
how much to Ukraine we could have easily
how much is the did they say the border
is going to cost 50 billion we could we
had the money we gave it to I think he
wanted five billion I don't give a damn
we could have done it they did it on
purpose what I'm I'm saying is
everything is done on purpose there
there's no well we love Mexican no no no
you don't love you want to destroy
the country let's talk about what
happened here okay Larry Elder drops out
endorses Trump Penn suspense campaign
for president because apparently if you
can pull up this picture Rob he couldn't
get 15 people to show up to a pizza
party and apparently his campaign
afterwards is like we got to we got to
wrap this up just just just Google it
and you'll see it if you just type in
Rob type in uh 15 Pizza pens just with
15 Pizza pens uh uh uh and the story
should come up uh he was he was once a
favorite of the right now Mike Pence
can't get a crowd of 15 to Pizza Ranch
15 to Pizza Ranch so he's out Nikki
Haley continues her Ascent ties to
santis for second in Iowa uh gold
standard pole which Tom I think you
called this let me read this yeah two
weeks ago I said next you said this
that's right Nikki haly Republican
president can has sergeon Iowa's gold
standard poll tying with Florida
Governor Ronda Sanz for second place
both at 16% marks a significant gain for
Haley who increased her support by 10%
since August while the santis Lost 3% of
his support and Marsh Donald Trump let
in the nation GOP Primary polls with
45.9 followed by the santis 30.1 Haley
in fourth place at 4.3 currently Trump
enjoys
60% while the gap between the santis
12.6 Haley 8.3 has steadily been closing
in Iowa the santis has the support of
28% of Voters in miday to at least 5 a
half% now 17.3 to 11.3 Tom why do you
think this is happening uh there's two
two reasons why it's happening um to the
average Republican voter they know Nikki
Haley as a Warhawk and they trust her as
a strong defense individual and so when
we have these things going on uh I know
for fact that the um uh Israel Lobby
trust Nikki Haley and what's happening
right now in times of uncertainty people
say now wait a minute wait a minute
who's really going to be the guy there
you can remember uh Jay Leno walking out
after 9/11 and actually saying that he
was glad that it was Bush and Cheney in
the white house when you know okay what
are you really saying Jay well you know
if it was Al Gore ringing his hands what
do we do what do we do instead it was uh
W out there at the bullhorn saying at
911 to all you workers all you Rescuers
I can hear you and soon they will hear
from us remember that famous speech yeah
what's happening right now is people are
are reacting to the war in the Middle
East especially um is the uh Jewish
people in America which been and you
know I've lived around lots of them all
my life and I can see their fear I can
see their concern they don't like what
they see on schools and it's all showing
up in Nikki's polling um uh Rob do you
have real clear politics and then go to
Iowa and then break it down to the
recent Iowa polls so we can see the hard
numbers in here go real Court politics
go to election
Iowa hit the little Iowa box over there
on the on the right it'll pop all pop
them
up there you go now go look at the most
recent one don't look at the chart look
up at the top up top up up up the most
recent one right up there the one of the
most recent dates look at those numbers
look at those
numbers it's been in the last where are
the numbers Tom I don't see any of the
numbers he bounced off right there see
Trump is up went from 1711 say take a
look at DES santis Haley
1711 just in the 106 to 1010 poll now
the 1022 1026 it's 1616 she's actually
inherited a little bit from Trump you
see that Pat so you don't look at the
that the amalgam of polls you look at
the most recent one that was the de Mo's
register is deemed to be a very accurate
barometer as they go campaigning people
are turning to Haley because they they
see her as a strong right-wing war hawk
by the way if you look at this it's so
interesting CBS is definitely not a
trump uh place no and neither is uh the
rest but Fox Business has Trump lower
than CBS does uh at the same time yeah
very interesting on how Fox is
definitely not a trump side today Fox
the fox's crew they're they're not pro
Trump although they were four years ago
they're not today
at least it seems like it and I think in
New Hampshire Nikki Haley is is um I'm
waiting they haven't had a national poll
release I mean a local credible poll
released nationally in New Hampshire in
3 weeks you don't need to go there Rob
but if and if you went there you would
see we have a lot of stale poles up
there and when and I think I personally
think there's a little bit of
gamesmanship going on in the polls
because the core Republican um you know
establishment that that wants DeSantis
or Trump probably doesn't want to see
the next New Hampshire poll pop up
because Haley's coming up for the same
reasons here look uh when's the third
debate you tell me it's yeah it's
November 8th here in Miami okay Rob fat
check that we're about to see these
candidates start dropping like flies
four already right the
two come on buddy Elder governor and
Governor yeah I mean Mike Pence come on
you can't even get 15 people to a pizza
party you want people to come to your
rally it's not happening Mike Pence then
here's what's going to happen happen
next uh Doug berham you know he's going
to be out Tim Scott thanks for playing
buddy this ain't your time no VC you
smooth talking smart Rich nobody Brown
smart dude and SC may be on stage
happening I'm just saying they're going
to start dropping they're going to be on
stage Tom but they it's the JV debate
all right then you got Nikki Haley all
right you know un Ambassador okay woman
president stop it Tom and then last but
not least uh Des santis he was here
yesterday look I don't want to say this
about the santis great guy policy guy
love them you know I love them in the
setting I love them in the one-onone
setting we know he's
5'9 we know it what's the big deal
what's the big deal I just own it say
you like wearing boots I'm wearing boots
pbd yeah it's fine but here's the deal
uh you got to have some swag you got to
have some RZ you got to have what these
kids are talking about you know some uh
you know kicking him with the boys typ
out he don't got it yeah but he's smart
as do you think you what he did for
Florida was great to Sanz of course but
this ain't his time but well and it was
disloyal well here's my question to you
do you think with all the stuff that
they're doing with Trump is the effort
of the left the the blatant using the
law to go after Trump to make him
unrunnable to him Vinnie it's election
denial okay it's election interference
it's interference it's not Deni let me
let me say this real quick by the way
can I ask you guys a question who who
prevented World War who was the one that
was able to stand up to Hitler which's a
Churchill okay uh without looking can
you tell me how how tall you think
Churchill is Churchill is a short fat
round guy he had ball five five
six understanding is he was Square as he
was I would
sayon Churchill is Rob G
if one of the greatest lead of all time
was 5'6 yeah but he didn't give a
yeah it's the part of the brand no he
didn't give a who melini was 5'7
you Napoleon was a but the point
is the point is it's when it comes down
to Leading if you can get the job done
nobody cares nobody cares if he can get
the job done everybody wants to like how
tall is Tom Cruz by the way can you pull
up how tall is Tom 58 58 58 57 which who
has he not dated in Hollywood 57 who has
he not dated in and by the way type in
my height type my height Patrick David
Tom Cruz is bang some of the hottest
girls b b David I like that up for me
I'm five uh 5657 on some places I'm 54
on you put Pat up there put Pat Patrick
bat David let me see where pat p were
you five something on here no you'll see
there's 5'4 there's 5'7 there's five all
this stuff there's 57 right there 557
Pat five five
154 lb so but here's the point ladies
and gentlemen that was me standing on
the right of him Pat was on the left the
point the point is the point is when it
comes out to leadership nobody cares how
tall you are you just got to own up to
it and be like this is who I am let me
just go out there and do what I'm doing
hey do the Eminem from E mile that's all
you got to do here's who I am here's
what I'm doing here's my brand you like
it GD you don't like it let me get back
and spend time My Wife and Kids man
that's what I'm going to do you know
either I'm going to you think by the way
here's the thing how hard you think the
job is to be a president how tough of a
job you think hardest job in the world
look at actually think about it though
how hard is that job look remember when
Obama went in he looked viral he looked
two years later he looked like wide he
look it took actually I've read about
this they say you look at the before and
after pictures from inauguration four
years later and you look at the stress
in terms of like the wrinkles around the
eyes they say it has got to be
absolutely factually the most stressful
job in the world of course course bro
you're the leader of the Free World and
everybody knows Joe Biden if he gets
elected on a second term which obviously
if I have sentence anything about it
ain't going to happen nobody wants to
see kamla Harris oh God think about that
g did you see our interview on 60
Minutes horrible
uncomfortable it's not it's not about
even about being horrible was disturbing
to watch okay let's go to couple other
stories talk about musk offer starlink
internet for recognizing organizations
and Gaza okay this is from Times of
Israel musk is coming in here okay so
billionaire musk on Saturday said that
Starling satellite service would support
internet access for internationally
recognized eight organization in Gaza
which have faced a telecommunication
blackout since Friday musk who own
starlink operates SpaceX was responding
to a post by us Democrat Congressman AOC
in which she called the communications
blackout and gasa unacceptable Israel's
Communications ministro Min by the way
eventually AOC and Moscow are going to
dat
eventually that's going to happen
because he keeps listening to what she
has to say and every once in a while he
gives her what she wants K tweeted
Israel will use all means at its
disposal to fight Hamas will use for
terrorist activities there's no doubt
about it we know it and musk knows it
Hamas is Isis perhaps musk would be
willing to condition it with the release
of our abducted baby sons daughters
elderly people all of them by then my
office will cut any ties with starlink
okay so what do you think about this
move that Elana is doing Tom or Vinnie
or Tom Adam any opinions well I mean Pat
at the end of the day I get the war it's
a war Israel's not playing games
Netanyahu was it yesterday he was like
there's no ceasefire basically saying I
don't give a man woman child
innocent or not the goal is to kill
Hamas and we don't care who else gets it
we're going to wipe out that entire
place I they cut off all electricity all
everything Elon mus cuz mind you not
everybody there is Hamas how many Hamas
are in inside of uh Gaza 50% listen no
they're not it's 40,000 part of the
government 40,000 is Hamas out of 2
million it's 40,000 so uh and goes so I
I think P some people obviously they
need communication they need to
communicate with their with their loved
ones to let people know that they're
alive because guess what there's
Palestinians that have family members
here in the United States um but uh I
have a question Pat and I I know you
know that I tweeted this since the
terror terrorist attack how many
Palestinians you think have been Ked
killed since since October 6
Palestinians how many 8500 it's it's
gone up to almost 9,000 today all right
the majority of those are women and
children it's a fact you debate me all
day my question is this how many Hamas
have been killed in that 9 to 10,000 if
how many if you had to I'm guessing Tom
is there a number is there a Hamas
tracker that we know and my other
question is how many civilians I get the
attitude of just what we don't care well
netanyahu's attitude was did did America
stop purple Harbor did America stop
during 911 okay I get it you want to
wipe out Hamas all of us do but a how
many Hamas have been killed and number
two what is the limit what's going to be
the number if there is one of Civilian
casualties the majority being the youth
is the number going to be enough for
them to say okay now we're going to
chill now we're going to do a ceasefire
cuz the goal is to protect Israel put
your defenses up don't let some
something like that happen again I want
to know that because Tom there is no
number of Hamas dead I haven't seen it
yet I I understand what you're saying
and your numbers are standing up what
what I haven't seen is I have not seen
like UNICEF and Red Cross going in on
mass trying to help the people there
because they can't because this is a
live war zone and so when mus says I
want to do this for internationally
recognized Aid organizations I don't
think there are any internationally
recognized Aid organization that are all
the way in getting in it is a hot war
zone Egypt has got the Border closed
right Israel's got the Border closed
Israel's also got the blockade on the
other side uh you know the uh the uh
southern side that faces basically the
desert so basically I don't know that
there's International Aid organizations
in there that are going to be helped by
Communications at this hour because it's
a hot war zone however I support what
he's doing at the earliest possible
moment I understand Israel saying hey
this just going to be used for terrorist
activities cuz they're going to use the
communication and intercept it I get
that and I think that there's some truth
in that but I I think this is a good
gesture by musk but I think it has to
come at a time where we get a ceasefire
or we get get get this thing to go from
a a hot theater at least to just a very
warm theater but it's not but Tom it's
not going to stop if when you hear the
leader saying we're not stopping we
don't care who it's no ceasefire we're
wiping I don't know and mind you you can
support the innocent people and not be
anti-israel or be anti-semitic or be a
Hamas supporter I give a about the
people the the the majority people there
are innocent people can we agree to that
Jimbo look I'm going to tell you what I
agree with and what I disagree with um I
I want to annihilate Hamas okay is it
how many lives how many hear Million
Lives are worth it to I don't I don't
want to see any zero inoc lives in this
horrible tragedy I think what BB
Netanyahu Israel look uh the first week
two weeks pure emotion rage
retribution and I think they need to go
back to the drwing board and they need
to understand that in war above all you
need to win the hearts and Minds MH and
they're up against Hamas funded by Iran
BFF with Hezbollah Isis Al I think we
can agree
that Hezbollah Isis Al Qaeda Hamas they
are death Cults okay that want to just
kill people
Americans certainly Israelis and we need
to name them for what they are radical
Islamic terrorists 100% but that doesn't
mean that everyone over there is one
there may be some that are sympathizers
right there's also um the there there
also needs to be an understanding that
look at the the war in Ukraine nobody's
even talking about it right now y why
it's not a it's not on radar you know
how many wars are going on in the world
right now dozens yep Armenia aeran let
are we not going to talk about that
there's other going on but is
Israel you know 2% of the world all eyes
are on them and they need to understand
that you were playing a information
campaign or a lot of times a
disinformation campaign you got to win
the pr war and you can't do that by
bombing innocent people now here's the
deal M uh a lot of times this
information comes from Hamas the whole
Hospital parking lot Fiasco it's been
proven
y'all Islamic Jihad shot the rocket
landed in a parking lot they pumped the
story out to the leftwing media
and they ran with it but Israel needs to
win the hearts and mind of the people
and then lowkey shut the up and go
in there you know how many miles of
tunnels there are 300 miles of tunnels
that's where they that's where they are
you're not going to get to theel have
the video of them blowing up the tunnels
do you have that video you're not going
to get to the tunnels by using Air
Supply yeah air you see what jao willick
had to say watch what he had to say okay
but and But but so here's my thing Pat
he just said we're in dozens of War
we're the Ukraine Russia's fighting you
know China's you know trying you know
they have ships going Israel and
Palestine are going on we're obviously
fighting overseas as well here's my
question to you Pat what what
constitutes World War I what is there a
moment where you go okay is there an
announcement cuz everybody's fighting
everybody in the world is is fighting
right now this is what we need to see
more of from Israel certain tactical
explosions from underground yes I can
deal cuz who are they killing Vinnie
let's not be here who are they
killing that right to see those building
who are they killing under there hold on
hold on they're killing terrorist yeah
you see those buildings though that are
standing up still those are still intact
you're not wiping it out because
apparently you got information that
there was one Hamas terrorist in that
apartment complex so you level it and
you ruin the lives of God knows how many
people in there there has and I'm happy
that your your attitude is less civilian
casualties no nobody wants it but when
you have a leader saying you know what I
don't give a we're not ceasing any
fire we're wiping the everybody's
going bye-bye you you have the ceasefire
video it's all over Twitter you can play
the clip you know what's going to happen
to BB Netanyahu what do you know what
this is his fifth term maybe his sixth
term longest standing 10e prime minister
in Israeli history do you know want to
know what's going to happen with this
man you know you've said things like
maybe he you know pulled a standown
order you know what's happened to his
legacy said hold on I never said that I
said it was the oddest thing ever that
do you know what's going to happen to
his legacy what you understand that he's
going to have to resign his whole
mission is economic prowess and
safety okay that ain't happening my
point is that's what he ran on and
that's why he was elected and the worst
massacre of Jews since the Holocaust
happened under his watch under his watch
you think he feels good about that you
think that's something that he wants you
think that when when it goes down for BB
nyah's Legacy he had to resign in
disgrace
so these people to think that you know
oh he wanted this get the out of
here he's going to have to resign and
his whole Coalition okay the leud party
and unfortunately they might even elect
further rightwing people great play this
clip I want to make clear Israel's
position regarding a
ceasefire just as the United States
would not agree to a ceasefire after the
bombing of Pearl Harbor or after the
terrorist attack of 911 Israel will not
agreed to Association of hostilities
with Hamas after the horrific attacks of
October 7th mhm calls for a
ceasefire our calls for Israel to
surrender to Hamas no to surrender to
terrorism to surrender to
barbarism that will not
happen ladies and gentlemen the Bible
says that there is a Time For Peace and
a time for war this is a time for war a
war for our common future today we draw
a line between the forces of
civilization and the forces of barbarism
it is a time for everyone to decide
where they stand Israel will stand
against the forces of barbarism until
Victory I hope and pray that civilized
Nations everywhere will back this fight
because Israel's fight is your fight
because if Hamas and Iran's AIS of evil
win you will be their next Target that's
why Israel's victory ictory will be your
Victory but make no mistake regardless
of who stands with Israel Israel will
fight until this battle is won and
Israel will prevail may God bless Israel
and may God bless all those who stand
with
Israel when you when you say something
like that okay first of all bringing in
America obviously mentioned like well if
America did this we have to do this and
then you're bringing the Bible you're
trying like you said you're winning the
hearts minds but at no point what is the
civilian casualty number that is
sufficient for you to say Hamas is gone
CU if the goal is to annihilate Hamas
you cannot do that that's not a feasible
goal Adam there's no Hamas tracker
number and the word terrorism it's
always dude terrorism is like the bell
bottoms of propaganda and fear and it
can always come back and come back into
Style terrorism you're not going to win
that battle and having the attitude of
we're not going to stop then 9 what what
would you say the percentage of
civilians men women and children are
going to die in that over Hamas what's
the what's the number if you have to
guess Tom Hamas soldiers dying cuz this
ain't stopping they the ground war is
happening ships American ships are in
route right now to go help what do you
think Tom I I I I can't take a take a
guess I'm not telling you're not you're
not facts you had Vinnie and I'm not
trying I don't think you're trying to
bet me into a corner I'm saying I can't
make an estimate for you other than to
say that the civilian loss of life of
people who are are Palestinians is
horrifying equally horrifying was what
started this game obviously but what's
the number I want to I I need I want to
guesstimate Adam Pat guys let me ask you
I'm I'm going to say 8% Civ I think 80%
civilians are dying and 20% H let me ask
you that's my opinion after the the
raping and pillaging and beheading of a
couple thousand Israelis 1600 okay
that's a bad number still hor hold on a
horrible moment what's disgusting moment
thank you what's an
appropriate reaction what's an
appropriate amount of people that will
have to die what's
appropr how about this hold on I don't
want any civilians dying but the manner
that is happening right now Adam cuz I
was in the mil I know these type of
tactics it's just obliteration that's
not the way to do it you nailed it with
the with the caves with the tunnels blow
them shits up why hasn't that been
happening more than just have you hold
on have you seen Gaza right now what
Gaza actually looks like it looks like
ground Z 911 it's flattened Adam I still
where where's the Hamas number we're not
hear let me ask you why don't you have
the same energy for the people of
Ukraine what do you mean why don't you
have the same energy of the people of
Armenia why don't you have the same
energy for the people the innocent
people are dying in the cono I'm asking
you mean I don't have that same you
never gone on like this hold on a hold
on a second how much so where's that
energy Adam first of all any I'm going
to say this again any civilian life
that's lost especially when I see kids I
got emotional last week Adam because I
saw a child shaking with shell shock
while his mother was dying on the floor
I I don't want any of it happening and
the passion is happening right now Adam
cuz it's happening right now and they're
using our name in it I'm I'm not anti-
Ukraine and US sending the money and
doing all that I don't want none of
that happening but this is in our face
right now and the leader is saying we
don't give a we're wiping we're
wiping everybody out come on man you
have to have some humility in here's my
concern let me tell you guys what my
concern is okay and obviously all of
this stuff that you're watching seeing
uh it's pretty bad because we're getting
more and more immune to it like it's
becoming a normal Tuesday normal Monday
normal like gun violence in America yeah
so if you look at this here's what
you'll see erigon threatens to declare
war on Israel and send military to Gaza
in chilling warning okay recap no
erdogan delivered a speech if you can
pull this up to a rally in which he told
attendees Israel was responsible for war
crimes and framed Hamas as Freedom
Fighters obviously we know Hamas is not
Freedom Fighters in comments that have
promoted prompted Israeli outcry and
leted the country to withdraw its
diplomatic presence president erdogan
suggested assault Gaza constitute a
massacre erigon reportedly said from now
on we will continue on our path with the
motto that we may suddenly knock on your
door one night he said in the past they
were massacring the Jewish people and
the gas Chambers and they were indeed
wiping out whole regions with bombs then
he added a similar mentality is being
shown in Gaza today okay all right so
Eragon um he's talking about a massacre
that's exactly what he was okay with
aeran doing to Armenia he wasn't saying
moral authority to talk about genocide
you want to talk about a guy that
doesn't have exactly he said let me not
remind Armenians of what we did to you
many years ago that can happen again
this is a he said that oh yeah this
guy's a straightup gangster what Eragon
is he's a straightup gangster this guy's
not a lightweight he's a True Believer
and he's one that you you know at the
same time turkey's military strong
military if you type in one of the
strongest militaries in the Middle East
type in strongest military in the Middle
East strongest military in the Middle
East yeah okay see see what comes up 10
strongest I think he's top he may even
be number one but he's top three for
sure he's top three wow then is UAE okay
keep going which doesn't say much then
is Iraq keep going then it's Morocco
keep going then it's Syria keep going
Algeria keep going Saudi fifth
Iran fourth wow Israel third Egypt guess
who's left wow turkey are you serious
they have the strongest military in the
Middle East ground in air by the way
those are our planes weapons and
everything that are in turkey and Israel
so so he is sitting there saying you
want to do something okay so look at
that number right there you see 355,000
that's 2017 Hamas is 40k Hezbollah is
150k uh Israel I think is 300,000 if
they get their Reserve this is active
Personnel active they got 355 Israel
doesn't have 355 active Okay so this is
not if you wake these guys up so now
watch this let's say turkey gets
involved say Iran gets involved say
Israel is obviously involved Hamas is
obviously involved Iran gets involved
Hezbollah is definitely involved and
then next you know sai's got to get
involved and then from there NATO's got
to get involved us has got to get
involved everybody's like wait a minute
you're getting a little too close to
Europe what are we doing with this
Russia's got to get involved China's got
to get involved in no time this is World
War II and this is one of the reasons
why I asked the question yesterday of
the governor there's three things very
basic number World War I 19 million
people died 90 million casualties World
War II 60 million casualties if we
follow that Trend World War II will be
200 million
casualties the the entire thing is about
finding a way to calm people's nerves
down get people to say guys relax guys
let's figure this thing out but
unfortunately Left Right Center the
buyers remorse Community doesn't believe
in their
president people who didn't vote for him
they already don't believe in him but
people who did vote for him are having
buyers remorce a big percentage of them
they don't see him as somebody that's
intimidating they don't see him as
somebody that's going to go out there
and have the conversation with him that
that visual we saw on the plane on the
Air Force One when blinking is behind
him is like oh my God don't say anything
don't say anything take the cameras off
and his chin looked a little bit weird
everybody thought it was somebody else
that was talking like that can't be him
that's got to be somebody else moral the
story even though with all this stuff is
going on this is when you value somebody
that knows how to bring the temperature
down Biden doesn't have the ability to
bring the temperature temperature down
you know when you first start h people
and you're running a company you know
how you look at somebody as a employee
you're like oh I like him he's going to
be great second time you hire like dude
that did not work out okay third time
you hire by the time you're hiring
people you're 50 at 100 200 500 time
we've hired I don't know thousand
employees or 15 on the insurance side
I've 45,000 insurance agents imagine how
many people we've hired over the years
you know what you start realizing you
start realizing what qualities matter
the most yesterday we having a
leadership meeting my Monday morning Co
meeting that I do and one girl I say hey
the one guy that works he seems like
he's always happy we need more positive
people here cuz there's nothing worse
than having negative people in the
office that always are Petty it's not
fair it's not this it's not that oh my
gosh it you realize the value even Elon
Musk in his book talks about that Talent
is great everything is great but nothing
is above a positive attitude a great
attitude you can teach them skills you
can teach them how to do things you
can't teach them that stuff where am I
going with this the American voter
has to get better at picking the
employee that is doing the job for us
and one of the things you have to judge
the person you hire is can they lower
the temperature to prevent a World War
II you don't prevent a World War III by
going out there and killing people you
prevent a World War III by everybody
knowing if you do cross the line it's
going to be horrible like you know what
Trump said a couple days ago if 1 ounce
of blood what did he say a couple days
ago if they drop 1 oce ofer americ blood
I'm going after gallons from you spill a
drop of ours I'll spill a gallon of
yours so but you know what America needs
that America needs that America needs
somebody like that right now so my
entire we can have this debate back and
forth back and forth back and forth what
is going to prevent World War III is
probably the most beneficial thing for
everybody that's probably going to be
the most beneficial thing for everybody
we absolutely need strong leadership and
I'll paint the picture for you a little
worse remember you know there's the NATO
Clause that says if you attack one all
will defend and that yep and that was
why that that was why Russia did not
want an official joining of NATO by
Ukraine because it means everybody's
there which was a southern European
country controversial at the time that
joined NATO in
1952 turkey turkey has been a member of
NATO since 1952 so if Turkey turkey and
by the way he just said they may he just
said a couple months ago that they may
step away from being a member of NATO I
don't know if saw and by the way they're
stepping away with NATO arms and NATO
training and and American Arms that have
been provided to the NATO countries we
don't give them all the tricks we don't
give them we don't give them the war
planes with everything but they've got
very serious armaments and so a turkey
saying okay I'm I'm doing this I'm in
that basically means we're at war with
our own equipment we're war with
ourselves is so horrible we need a
leader to stand up and the world is
never safer never safer and the United
States is never safer and the diverse
people of the United States are never
safer than when the guy in the White
House is thought of to be the the bully
by The Bad actors when Reagan was
inaugurated moments after he was
inaugurate it was hours later Iran had a
deal hey you know we we figured out how
we can get the hostages back here we go
here's your boarding pass remember that
when the rest of the world says that the
American leader is nuts when you've got
Al Qaeda says Reagan's nuts when you
have the the Eastern European dust pots
at the time saying that the American
leader is nuts the world is safe and
when people were saying that Trump was
nuts and I know he wasn't nuts he's not
nuts he was out there standing for
Freedom standing for the us but guess
what the rest of the world was a nervous
around them and you know what that is
not a bad thing when the bad guys become
nervous and no Wars no Wars under Trump
you're exactly right and it takes a
Statesman who the rest of the world
thinks is not a py or a pushover this
guy's got no credibility Eran okay he's
absolute hypocrite okay The Armenian
Genocide 1919 yep okay what's going on
1915 what's going on in aeran today you
know Lindsey Graham calls him the turkey
the squad of NATO you can't trust these
guys right here so it's disappointing
it's uh destabilizing for NATO with this
guy erdan but you know he calls it war
crimes his musle you don't think he's
done war crimes you don't think he's
going what's going on so you know be
careful you're getting your advice from
is all I'm saying no it's not about be
careful where you're getting your advice
from this is this is this is we're on
the same This Is War crime on steroids
that this guy's got but let me tell you
got blood on his and and to me this
isn't about positive energy preventing a
war this FYI folks if you if you if
you're wondering where I stand with if
we're already in it or not we're in it I
already said over happing mean the way
my strategy what I said is to not have a
person like Biden as your president y
That's my strategy my strategy is from
day one it's too late the moment
somebody knows they can't fear you it's
over that took a second the way
Afghanistan we left and from there this
is happening under Biden's watch of
course did this this Russia Ukraine and
Afghanistan happen under his watch look
at the scoreboard y' buyers remorse yep
I got it it buyers remorse at the
highest level buyers remorse at the
heist let me see if we got one more
chance for One More Story do one more PD
let's do one more I'm going piss my
pants I drink of beer I'll be back in 30
second okay go forward ex New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo says Joe Biden
should face Democratic primary so Mo has
I think $5 million left in his pack and
I'm not sure he is going away Andre Como
and I'm not sure he's happy about the
fact that everybody got rid of him out
of nowhere at a time where everybody
thought he was going to be the next
president going up against Trump Andrew
KO the former New York Governor has
called for a democratic challenge
against Biden in 2024 and I think there
should be a Democratic primary Kom cries
criticized Biden for distancing himself
from allegations against him referring
to the Tera read case and expressed
doubts about Biden's strength as
candidate saying I don't know that
candidate Biden is the strongest
candidate we can put up frankly I doubt
it he urged the Democratic party to
engage with voters on a different level
emphasizing the need for a affirmative
strategy to win elections Koma also
criticized the slogan defund the police
calling it The Three dumbest words ever
uttered by the Democratic party
Tom uh Andrew cromo says if you're
looking for somebody else I'm right here
that's basically what he just said and
he did it by providing some facts and
some basis and some foundation for his
argument
why don't we have a democratic process
and have candidates and an Open Primary
do we think Biden is the best I don't
think so let's have a primary and uh by
the way he he announces one of his
campaign pledges Pat I think defund the
police is one of the three dumbest words
ever uttered by the Democratic party it
sounds like a guy who wants to look like
a moderate doesn't it this is Andrew
cromo saying I think we need an Open
Primary and ladies and gentlemen I'm
right here I I will be in that's what
he's saying you think he had the chance
to p
like in all honesty I think I think the
the the table's already set for like
it's obviously in our face Pat Uh Biden
is not going to run there's absolutely
no way that he's going to run and I I
definitely think uh Nome and I'm telling
you man when Roger Stone said it he said
it a while ago he goes don't be
surprised if Michelle Obama comes out of
nowhere and he goes take that to the
bank he goes remember I'm the first one
that said it I I just I obviously I
don't trust them I think they something
up their sleeves that's going to be
coming but Pat there's no there's no way
they picked who they wanted the swamp
knows who they want I mean they wouldn't
Biden's the perfect stay there we'll
tell you what to say your handlers will
move you here and if God forbid he dies
or he falls and breaks his neck guess
what kamla is right there and she's
she's one of them what do you can I can
I do a little um you know I don't know
remember remember that idiot that used
to be on late night TV Miss Cleo you
would call her and she would tell
Fortune let me be a little fortune
teller how how does Governor ex-governor
andw Cuomo feel about watching the semi
anointing of Gavin Nome this guy comes
from a family that was a pillar of the
democratic party he led a blue State he
led you know uh policy that the Democrat
Party felt was beloved Andrew Cuomo was
a Statesman and a leader in that party
and now he's looking half all the way
across the United States to the
anointing of a relative rookie in Gavin
Newsome I gotta believe Pat that there
maybe is a little bit of athletic um
jealousy here going on because I happen
to think Andrew Cuomo if you is a is a
Democrat I think he's I think he's
formidable I think the S Nome is
formidable I think they I'd love to see
Cuomo in there by the way if you look at
the resume of dirt there's not a single
person that's going to run at that level
that's not going to have dirt yeah if
you man if you compared dirt of Andrew
Koma versus Bon Bon's killing him the
score is 71 to one touchdown okay is
what the score is Bon's against uh
Andrew CUO so and that's a whole
different conversation anyways we're at
the end of the podcast here gang Adam is
officially the first person ever to go
is this a third time or it was the
second time been drinking beers all
morning chers let's
go let's go even I
love respect can I give a quick message
got 30 seconds I got I to say something
too quick quick guys I love you I know I
know I know you give me a hard time but
we're getting better improving yeah
we're doing our thing I I appreciate you
bearing with me I was left I was
moderate you know getting there guys I'm
getting there guys obviously okay guys
let me just I we got to wrap up guys I
said 30 seconds we're g both of you guys
Town Hall December 6th RFK we be at the
5990 live studio
come meet them take pictures some of you
will be at the Cigar Lounge with them
afterwards the link will be in the
description some of you guys if you text
the word podcast to 3103
41132 you already got the link I'm
seeing tickets already being purchased
left and right it was already text. go
to 5990 live 5990 live to purchase
tickets V 5990 live.com to purchase
tickets for the town hall with RFK on
December 6th at the club in Fort
Lauderdale comes see us we're looking
forward to having you guys there take
care everybody bye-bye bye-bye
December